hello everyone and welcome to another
round of the feed hs.com grand swiss
currently being played in riga latvia we
have a really really cool game between
badr jobaba uh georgian grandmaster and
french grand master jill moussard and uh
well it just shows you that when the
when such strong players are out of
protective waters of theory uh very
early on in the game uh anything can
happen and uh if you've seen some of
your baba's games that we've shown on
this game on this channel you know that
when he's playing you know everything is
just hanging pieces are just flying all
over the place uh and this game isn't
all that different so without further
ado let's check it out and see what uh
what happened here so
about which the white piece opens with
e4 we have e5 and now d4 the the center
game uh we have e captures on d4 and now
knight to f3 uh if you want to further
go with uh you know gambits you could
also play some like c3 and if captures
even bishop to c4 but this isn't all
that great for white even though it
looks scary black is perfectly fine here
uh and if someone plays this against you
you know you should really know how to
uh you know take care of this with black
there are many ways to take care of it
but uh you know some people play it so
maybe maybe now you should check it out
uh but okay for this game we have the
con knight to f3 and now bishop to be
for check and c3 is the standard move
here just c3 characters knight captures
black is up upon and white of course
enjoys his uh uh well uh for the moment
lead in development but here we have
knight b to d2 it's a move that's been
played only once so far uh and the game
continued with queen to a7 but already
here we have d5 challenging white's e4
pawn and it is now as of move 4 that we
have a completely new game so here
knight captures on d4 now a point being
that if d captures on e4 we're going to
play c3 defender knight attack the
bishop and then collect the de for pawn
so a mussar goes for knight to e7 and
now c3 we attack this bishop uh so
bishop back to c5 and now knight two to
f3 uh again uh sorry knight and knight
two to b3 defending this night here and
attacking the bishop uh that is much
better so bishop back to b6 and now the
ship to g5 so white getting some
development in and the black castles the
safety of course why shouldn't you the
white king is the one that's still in
the center of the board so e captures on
d5 now the knight can't capture the
queen has the capture on d5 if you want
to grab the pawn so queen captures on d5
giving up the knight on e7 but only
temporarily as you will be able to pin
the bishop and then easily win it or you
know you should be able to do that so
bishop characters on e7 and rook to e8
ready to pick up the bishop with check
on the next move and now we have knight
back to e2 and now what do you play here
uh you can't really capture the bishop
because your queen is hanging on d5 and
if you trade queens for example queen
captures rook captures uh you still
can't capture the bishop because of the
mate threat if we're captures we're just
going to play check and after rogue
blocks this will be checkmate so what
can you play after knight 82 well you
have to move the queen and the uh way to
do that is to play queen to f5 queen to
e5 also possible but uh queen to h5 uh
most certainly not even though this was
played in the game but now white has one
particular move that really wins the
game on the spot
so feel free to pause the video even
though it's only move 11 and win the
game for white well i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding this
really really difficult move to spot and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is queen to d2 that's the
move that's the movie and the black
cannot uh
uh continue playing this game uh the
game continues for a few more moves but
i'm just going to show you why it's
important because you really need to
guard that g5 square if you play
something like queen d3 and prepare
castling next uh even though black still
can't capture because of queen to d8 we
can play knight to c6 now just attack
the bishop twice and now after the
bishop moves es you can save it but now
for example bishop to f5 goes after the
queen and after we move the queen
somewhere even bishop to c2 the white
king is stuck in the center of the board
rook a is coming to d8 and that's just
gonna be game there there's no saving
this position if you try something like
king d2 we can even sacrifice the bishop
rook 88 checking captures here and now
queen f5 check that's it uh king to c1
we're going to play bishop captures on
f2 now attack the queen and after let's
say queen f3 offering a queen trade even
bishop to e3 check and now you either
give up the queen uh or you play
something like knight to d2 but that's
just you know giving up pieces captures
with checking the d1 bishop captures
here with checking the c1 we can do
another checking maneuver bishop g5
check and that's it once the king moves
we can simply capture here and deliver
checkmate so this is only one of the
lines uh but it just shows you how how
dangerous uh
it is so of course instead of this after
queen to h5 uh juba played the move you
all found and that is queen to d2 and
this is now a problem you still can't
capture the bishop because queen to d8
will lead to checkmate and now you're
covering that important g5 square
so what can you play here if you play
something like bishop to d7 now yes okay
uh you're threatening to pick up the
bishop but we simply move the bishop
bishop to g5 and that's it white is up a
piece white is completely winning here
or if you try something like knight to
c6 attack the bishop twice we can even
play queen g5 we really don't care now
you have to trade queens you have
nothing better captures captures we're
up a piece uh we're completely winning
uh so black tried h6 here uh kind of
allowing this king some breeding room
also taking away the g5 square from
white's pieces uh but uh it is much too
late for such things here job just
castles a queen side and uh there's
nothing for white to do a black to do
here black played knight c6 but now just
knight to f4 and he was in this position
uh on move 14 that uh resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
his queen is under attack uh once the
queen moves we're gonna move this bishop
we're gonna be up a piece with black
having zero compensation for this piece
uh to give you an example for example
queen f5 we can even start attacking the
black queen bishop d3 after queen e5 we
can play bishop to h4 we've saved this
bishop and that's it then of course a
move like g5 just uh you know loses to
rook h to e1 the queen has to move we're
going to pick up the rook and that's it
so really a fine example
after only 14 moves of how things can go
incredibly wrong uh when players are not
you know
sort of uh you know swimming in
protected
waters of known theory and it's just
just amazing so it would have all been
possible if the queen landed on f5
instead of an h5 but queen landing on h5
allowed you guys to find this
spectacular queen to d2 move and help of
course uh jobaba win this win this game
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it a bit of a shorter one
but i was i was very much surprised when
i saw that this happened i mean this
really doesn't happen that often so i
hope it was also uh uh uh something
refreshing for you but as it uh as it
turns out we will be showing the game
from board one uh
that that ferruja is playing uh so we'll
see uh how that one ends as you know uh
also pieces are flying all over the
place
uh so yeah once again i hope you guys
enjoyed that i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to holly zolt uh and i
would like to thank heather rose tom
darrell lucas de ocaries and james
mayberry for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event uh until it finishes
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world uh thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day